[Music]
hello guys welcome to next lecture today
and today we talk about games of the
week the this week having my play many
games I mean since last week having
played many games obviously but actually
today happened the most important ones I
would say because the chasuble masters
basically the finals are the lineup for
finals has been determined and today was
the first set of mini matches and my
wounds Carson's playing is Fabiano
Caruana sort of Reimers for a clutch
international that happened like lately
and yannis promised to play against what
is love artemiev so what all the matches
actually ended quite quickly after only
three games with a magical were supposed
to consist of four games but ended quite
quickly in three games
Magnus an infamous ji won their
respective matches so I will try to
cover today all those games but I'm
saying it very cautiously because I know
it's unrealistic is this basically
unrealistic because the time is limited
and there were so many things going on
those games that probably if I cover
let's say four I would be very happy
like we cover five in one of them would
be probably you know not so and many of
them would be not even very in-depth
just you know very important positions
will be you know I'll be happy with that
so let's get started with the first game
of talk about the first one was a game
of Magnus versus Fabiano
and this position I wanted to talk about
it first
basically this is typical from
some Queens gambit declined this is
cause both spawn structure white very
often tries to create a minority attack
upon minority attack on the Queen side
sometimes the Knights also try to block
it on the b6 c v v 65i five squares
depends of course what black is doing
and if it is possible black on the other
hand tries to cover the weaknesses maybe
apply f @ maybe p6 maybe prepare c5 at
some point times if what is before to
play b5 with an M be seasoned I see for
things like that - Peck Winifred is very
interesting move trying to try the
Queen's and if he can trade the Queen's
I'm not saying that this is great thing
for white but this is maybe a small step
in the right direction because
definitely black will have very little
counter play so it makes sort of sense
for y to trade Queens and then basically
prepare Queen side expansion so I would
still probably take if I were playing
black because right now I can play a 5
as black and this is who was the first
critical mode of this game I think that
probably probably have taken place it
was a 5 and try to play this position
but still after 92 I believe what is
slightly better let's say there are
ideas or maybe preparing before at some
point and between at c5 it's still
slightly better for white however it was
possibly the best what foreign I could
do wisdom is also possible however I'm
not such a big fan of this move right
now I believe that the Mario's could
have played here before or a5 both with
clear advantages however Hitler FC won
at first which is a good move but I
think that I really like fabulous
response Knight b6 the idea I'd be six
is to play right now move Knight c4 and
to be honest I still don't understand
why he didn't do it because he could
have done it he went for a completely
different approach but like after 96
let's say Mouse played before which is
typical
move as for my you know quick cars but
what structure and the Kings and
minority attack trying to play b5 of
course we can the pawn structure and so
on and right now if I haven't played
move rook a8 which is pretty much and
not understandable to me like I
understand I understand one part instead
he want to prevent b5 he prepares
against b5 but I'm probably miss coppery
something probably fine I just miss
probably something but I just think that
night c4 right now actually could give
decent chances for black to equalize
because let's see what happens this was
actually the the most accomplished in
the game this move right now at c4
because if he plays nicely for if white
tries to play Queen be for your queen a
to b5 the right now this dynasty for is
well supported and even though we have
created our own
I mean weakness on c5 9 c4 is very
strong and it's not easy to kick it out
from there and bases bother to kill the
best you can trade it but what does the
trade actually give to white not nothing
special really so position probably
still say where for white but back to
his not time is pretty solid so I don't
think [ __ ] will have had much problems
here may even though maybe his object is
still sorry words because what can
maneuver this art so 925 somehow tried
to strongly maneuver and so on but in
general block is doing quite well
so buggery to ask ourselves what to do
after Bishop takes c4 because we should
take c4 is XT for a5
simile is just creating policy for as a
chronic weakness and 94 95 or nights
knife or Knight b6 would be very good
for white because pound support will
just fall but here we come again with
the sort of was the most important
inches which is dynamics but dynamics
choices very dynamic game and the
statistically strategist logically
while is much better because policy for
will is just weakness of course if y
doesn't go a5 why would my plate just be
5 and by
just doing great however if after a 5 B
5 is impossible anymore because it will
jeopardize the pawn structure however in
this position black has very active and
dynamic approach to solve these problems
and actually even take over the
initiative and the way to do is Bishop
takes h3 and maybe this is what both
players missed by one deciding on you
know this position maybe you know when
this maybe this is why I didn't do it
because you think I'd leave it free here
but after take routing see free position
becomes extremely tactical and I believe
black should not be any worse here at
least there with some perpetual or some
some even maybe attack for instance 95 I
consider it if of course F times e3
queen g3 with Aliza perpetual at least
maybe even more most quimbo species on
the quiz are not doing anything are not
supporting the king so we're and it's
unlikely that black is in trouble here
possibly at least there's a little draw
for blackness for sure so if 95 rook
takes H freaking took we see it for
instance the Queen comes to a5 or maybe
rogue h5 Queen h3 h 5 Luke g5
whacking is very weak and also the spin
on 3rd rank is also NASM does make
things easier for for white so I just
think that it would be great position
for black around here so that's why not
c4 was the best at is practical attempt
because Luca is very passive mu doesn't
bring much is only prevents b5 idea but
after a 5 anyway after this move Knight
c4 right now it doesn't work anymore
because this is not a 4 is already very
bad because opponent III is covered
which which trees not a thing anymore
we white goes 96 or 95 95 points for
just Falls
so this is not possible anymore let's
see it then
if a brown play-doh after b5 I take
finite XB v - anyway managed to play I
mean conduct this minority pawn attack
on the Queen side and provoke more
weaknesses which Hemans eventually to
convert into a wind
just where was one more interesting more
and disposing this game or maybe here 94
was possible what anyway this is equally
bad I think for for black anyway what is
just much better here one important
thing here as in this game of course is
study better for I mean it's not even
cyber probably just much better because
it is a great version of the of the this
of this position destructor for wild
because pawns is weak and black doesn't
have even a pair of missions for this
usually there is at least pair officials
because what in many of those lines
black black white manages to take on f6
in regular let's say cars but variation
visual types of submission takes of six
and then a 4 B 5 and so on in here it is
basically what doesn't have a black
doesn't have you in this pair of pair of
bishops and if I was coming you know all
things like that so rook e8 bishop f1
happened pavo's was a pretty normal
definitely what is pushing for win and
right now this position Knight xe6 this
is not not that not only move of course
there is number of other possible moves
here for white but it is called a
transformation of the advantage and from
strategic advantage a Magnus decides to
go for something more tactical and try
to convert it into something else after
F takes G 695 suddenly broken B 6 & 7
are not cooperating quite well
Ruby 8 Queen eight seven still some
issues with the black pieces 90 is 5 2 X
is 5 of course we cannot take only 5
because only seven falls
28 and right now very nice move by one
by Magnus Bishop e2 mission comes to g4
tactically there are certainly those of
problems for for black and here final
final mistake final critical position of
this game in foreign play King h8 and
after this move Bishop g4 positions in
collapses he had to somehow play a
create some pressure on the screen and
try to maybe bring the Queen to her and
say Queen default Queen d7 try to let's
say be solid of course what is just was
still much better maybe Chris if I was
built more accurate but still the idea
of Queen d7 trying to keep the position
sort of tied together it would be the
best defense of course why this much
better anyway probably six the weak
response is the weakness and what can
improve the position number of ways
however it was the best defense because
after King age eight we should G for
position to simply collapsing ninety-six
a four and one mark is one upon second
phone and the game ended in few moves so
this is the first game I want to talk
about I think it went pretty smooth but
I know how many we can cover today I'm
trying to keep an eye on the clock
because I don't want to go over
overboard
so the second game from the first round
was nipple - G artemiev and it was also
a very interesting game and the position
I want to start talking about is
actually this one this is right after
the opening this was demolished a nice
variation in the rule opus and it is
black to play in this position it sort
of reminds me personally about King
Kings Indian defense where black Bishop
on g7 has been traded for white dark
square bishop and usually is this trade
is considered in blacks favor because
this Bishop understands very often not a
good Bishop cover still white has more
space why the sniper here and the
question is what to do here next was
black and Artemia came up here with very
interesting idea which is actually a
classical idea of playing right now move
Queen b8 Quinby 8 and as many of you
probably know classics there is the move
that acaba Rubenstein has played in I
don't know what was who's his opponent
but I think leonov's key I think enough
scheme not sure I think I know skip I'm
not entirely sure doesn't remark occupy
or Winston
played like in 1900 ad a game where he
played Queen b8 from the side eh
Queen b8 queen is seven Quincy five and
this is what ultimately does exactly in
the exact same pose disposition he goes
for the same idea however I'm not
entirely convinced where it's so great
right now and reason why is I think not
so great because what does this Queen do
once if I doesn't do very much and
instead it was bear easier to play
simply be six try to keep the quiz I saw
it or please see six here and try to
create some pressure that maybe Queen c7
and maybe play b5 at some point and cry
to cry to create the pressure on what
Center is which would be my probably
suggestion he might win ba which is very
interesting
that's why I start from this position
even though not much is going on well
like is the first moment where actually
you would see kind of like shift in the
let's say what one of the sides is doing
so be free happened
Queen eighty-seven we should be
frequency five the martyr managed to
bring his queen to c5 and right now I
don't think this was such a great idea
because I'm in general after Queen B -
right now I believe that Napoleon she
was just much better was just like died
like I don't see what was the next move
for for Artemia because if a for simply
before and one may say that okay if a
free because we are the Napo did if F
are also before works right but the
thing is after a 336 possible and this
white challenge what sooner is sort of
challenged if we play Queen B to first
c6 right now Brooke HC one if she takes
d5 Sita is d5
the queen is chased away and we have we
simply we don't need reate free move so
it was kind of like a waste of tiles of
tempe because actually also weakens the
queen style and instead we can we can
have robots t1 which is definitely in
our favor so a free happened c6 now
detects is six
it's possible approached and there is
nothing wrong with it
probably he didn't want to I mean the
right now Quimby to makes
the connection of a three so him
probably had to switch plans Ruby on
sauce possible over there before but
it's not anything like you know it's
just position I want to discuss like
this in detail because there are many
approaches possible Network chose this
one we see we shall be six before it is
before push up f1 and this is the second
one I want to discussed but before we I
suggest move right now for white I
wanted to point out why this Quinn b8
Queen SN Queens if I wasn't great know
what happened Queen was just raced away
from c5 was before Anna right now is
back to seven it was possible to just
play this quiz in just one move right
there was no necessity to go for all of
those maneuvers with the Queen it was
possible just play with one move even
though it is very that's a classic idea
and very nice idea in this position I
don't think he was so great so in this
position white to play and the Napo play
move Queen c3 and I don't know I'm not
sure whether it's such a great move
I think that bear move was 95 if 95 I
mean after 95 the idea could be to play
move c5 and then Knight takes c6 for you
and this would destroy the pawn
structure black's pawn structure for
good for instance if we play move like
some random of
a p84 is a bad move but just want to
point out the idea c5 is xt5 Knight
takes c6 left a z6 beat xt5 this is a
huge advantage for white pawn stars just
simply destroy those Knights have no
good squares I mean they have their
theoretically good square on the d4 but
it's impossible to get there right so
this is 95 therefore was a powerful move
because it's hard to prevent this c5
move it would black classified
themselves b5 who creates a passed pawn
and the opponent e6 could be also a
weakness so it's not I just think that
night if I was giving nappa big
advantage here instead of he played
Quincy free Quincy free is also possible
but doesn't really bring much because of
course I'm sense if I he must play but
when I deserve
it's all covered on only five on this
diagonal like there is no really follow
up to this so he plays rock 81 f6 making
making the position solid rock d2 trying
to play it one double and hit on d6 pawn
but again but right now our template
varies from of c5 and the area of c5 is
to simply hopefully of course for for
Artemis to win this fast square for the
for the night the safe route d1 and take
on before night c5 even if we give the
pawn would be pretty good position for
for black
however in b5 of course happens and
trying to create a passed pawn but right
now this has denied goes to b6 we're
also it locates the b-pawn and put some
pressure on the c4 pawn rook in d1 and
this is next quick opposition the next
important Creek opposition that I want
to talk about upon the sixth king right
and it's impossible to just leave it
like just like that and the fault but
what like has to defend it but the
question is how to do it and they're
simply as far as c4 ways to do it
where is rook ad a red rook idiot and
there is night BC it and night ec8 any
other move okay there's also not afford
to keep the Queen and I for one c3 but
simply makes no sense because Queens was
the will just retreat and anyway the
problem of the d6 pawn remains so our
time we have played rook idiot which is
the move I simply don't like and I
believe that if people did not eat c8
his position wouldn't be so so bad
because after night the thing is after
Luke idiot is this is a very passive
defense role this rug is sort of forced
to run out other protons pawn and cannot
find itself for itself any path to
activity at least at least this path is
elongated
a comparator comparing to what could
have happen if you played nice
you see it is a was a a very good move
of course the right now the idea is also
okay for it creates also a threat so
white has to defend someone from the
threat because we will say if h4 or
something the nuke a forward simply wins
the with the pawn on c4 so black has to
White has played Princess Roxie to the
queen of seven putting more pressure
Bishop e2 for instance trying to bring
this night to - if free for instance one
of the ideas but right now rook is 7 as
you can see as we can see who denied
protecting this pawn on d6 all the
pieces are relegated to different tasks
right now this rookie 7 root comes to a7
and black rooks actually create a
counter play on the FI Queen of 7 is
actually also hitting on c4 pawn which
makes the position makes the policy for
kind of like the worry a little bit for
for white here so I think this position
this may be still slightly better for
white but it's not anything tragic for
for our time of any more but if one as
it would be after Knight g5 earlier
let's say this rook a free rookie who
you are okay for putting the pressure on
c4 pawn definitely black has some
counter play here and especially with
the active rooks and on a file there is
it's not easy for y to improve the
position further round instead our time
in this position played hookie d8 and
after rook e8 b should be two rook d7
happened and I can idea knight of one
this is very nice idea bye-bye Napo and
finally
artemiy realized that he has to finally
defend this pawn on this eve of the
night so he played now night daddy see
it so what what have we achieved with
black basically black played rook e a
from E to d8 now 27 and then Twitter
instead it was possible to also the
Queen his on season now misplaced
normally would be ideal on placed on f7
but right now we still have to remove
our Queen one two three 12 7 and then
Luke only to place and black simply
waste so much time piece that right now
white
can create an attack on the kingside
because really getting back is the
queenside pink side is running a little
bit exporters there is only one Bishop
Macy's on the kingside right now so in
the center but like let's say covering
the king side
so right now 493 Queen being a ditch for
suddenly over there Bishop g4 suddenly
it's not easy for our time we have to
defend on the on the King side
he played move rook a for trying to put
some let's say resistance by putting the
pressure on c4 pawn but Bishop g4 takes
takes and we can see that this is like
for instance compare it to this position
this position right black actually put
pressure we're okay free right but in
this position it's a white already
already has played night h4 has played
Bishop g4 it's still on Brooks are still
on the default putting pressure on d6
pawn and the quiz on b8 not on f7 right
he's understand which is much more
active on the other position in the
other position which means on b8 where
it's very passive like here night h4
rotate for Bishop g4 takes takes Queen
a8 putting some pressure on e4 and this
next career couple of course there is
possible to play Queen c2 with just big
advantage however an apple pie move g5
which suddenly creates a big method of
this position and I believe that this
gives good winning chances for for white
even though objectively black has
chances to equalize and for instance
right now not time we have immediately
made a big mistake because he took after
95 his king size is basically nearly
collapsing so in the game happened Queen
takes e4 I mean this will happen the
game but better move was Queen takes e4
in mapping aftertaste king days of 6 9
f3 went to protect tonight the night c4
and this was this was the most critical
for the entire line
and in this position what has crazy and
stunning basically resource Knight takes
e5 I don't know if nepeta saw it but
like I wouldn't be surprised if he had
seen at least Queen takes 12 cores 94-94
and f4 of course the exit 5 is not
possible because of Route 87 so that is
far as a must
f4 Queen takes that for right now loses
to either rook of to Oregon however we
need to and put basically this position
of course very dangerous for black but
black is nearly lost here and there's
only one path for black to sort of halt
balance relatively still positions the
remains dangerous but after this King g7
is the best move it F takes e5 Queen
befores and basically only move and all
the spots was I simply crazy and I think
that what should by still has initiative
but somehow computers hold it at least
first after Queen c2 queenie for and
after Queen see one here Queen f3
basically trying to trade Queens by
enemies and eventually you know try to
escape for a draw so this was one this
was the best defense by by attaining but
you know this was rapid game he's moved
I'm a 36 probably both players Harold
like maybe two three minutes is not easy
to decide evidently quintics before so
he took on g5 which is also pretty
logical like okay like sort of
coarseness that will be discussed
earlier after HD 595 prove that you have
advantage right privilege or have enough
conversation for this piece so this was
also jackal but actually there is more
than enough conversation of a king Jade
Quincy free
what has crushing attack quintic c4
right now by the read a little bit too
late because after Queen to h4 King of 7
and right now what is simply winning
after for instance move Queen g7 Queen
Jason and what is just winning and of
course King yet Queen g8 mate if Queenie
King is 6 Queen h6 and
is very very important and nice move
Queen f6 the idea is that first of all
if King of start we just collect the
pawn and we have the same thing but we
collect the pawn and King average the
screen to screen Jade made and if King
f6 let's say Queen H says we got the
same position but we've already you know
we we've collected some materials so
it's very better version for us and if
Queen takes the five wide wins by
playing with f3 and kicking the Queen
away but also threatening g4 mate I mean
if the Queen lets it go someone to be 7
or 8 of course g4 mate so Queen has to
be given up after Quincy for g4 the X
takes route 84 and right now King h1
while is simply winning King is under
Keys Kings oh very exposed and black has
two knights which are let's say passive
there are some small very tiny hopes for
the fortress or something of that sort
but it is very unlikely with such a weak
King and there is still pawn b5 and what
has most importantly still two rooks on
the born the Queen which definitely give
which should give them in basically but
in this position king f7 rock d3 this is
what a NAPA plate and this is also very
interesting because ideas ruga free
right the seemingly it is just should
win on the spot but right now our
template amazing move rook a1 and
suddenly is not not the win anymore
right suddenly it's a draw suddenly it's
just a drop like Whitehead doesn't have
anything here more than a draw so in the
game happened rook they say one Queen
takes D free ok free trying to keep the
Queen out of the let's say Queen side
King side because they're safe King g7
Queen King g6
you know there is black black and
suddenly win so rookie freeze or
rippling for a draw we take the free and
after Knight h6
they still be perpetual check King f8
Queen Queen g5 assembly perpetual check
but there is small
and the salt end to this story because
after Queen f5 artemyev disconnected and
forfeited the game basically so dramatic
end as to the best of what I know what I
was what I followed so I know whether
were the rules about Tiber that kind of
like inkay what what was the rule about
you know this connection so on but the
Nepos claim was given a victory here so
I guess this was in the rules that he in
case of disconnection he wins but I
don't know anyway Nepal won this game by
this connection sort of right now but it
was very interesting one and there were
lots of interesting moments happening
starting basically the screen b8 we need
seven quincy five because I just
couldn't help myself and not to mention
this Rubenstein's idea because it's just
classic so alright let's go to the next
one and where this game would took quite
a lot so I'm not really not sure whether
we can finish all the games today from
this from this finals but anyway this is
the next one this is car carvanha
Carlson again and this is the second
game of this mini match and Caruana
Fabiano Carvalho was playing this rule 5
- playing with black and seemingly after
the opening black is you know just pawn
down like no compensation seemingly just
pawn down and that's it basically right
like just pawn up what foreigners
respond are should have greatest of
winning however it's not so simple the
bishop on e6 is extremely good blocking
piece it blocks the entire basically
King side and this extra pawn is the
kind you cannot really feel that there's
actually extra pounder you can create
easily
the any past pose on the kingside well
if we look on the Queen side even though
materials even on the Queen side - 2
versus 2 if we talk about pawns the
pollen i-4 and conical shape on b2 are
not such a great combination they're
basically object of the attack in the
future
bye-bye black so Roxy won't happen in
the game and the rook d3 but in general
I feel like black has easier easier game
after up d3 and the idea what is the
idea the ideas rugby 3 also rook a d8
bring the pieces maybe trade one pair of
rubes or or or or or something and then
challenge was a 4 and B 3 and B 2 pounds
it's not so easy to play this position
with with white for instance after B
rook if ruby free it doesn't work Fabian
PI which is a good move however there
was move Bishop d2 which is probably a
little bit more accurate and the idea of
Bishop d2 is to bring this bishop to c3
I'm not entirely sure whether it makes
such a big difference but I would
consider this move as as an interesting
one and it has small drawback because
after be something allows me short xh3
right and normally this is what black
should white wouldn't want black to do
but the thing is that we to realize that
we can't really hold this pawn and more
important is to actually provoke to get
this bishop out of a 6 square because
with this bishop we cannot actually do
here anything with white after we shot
xh free takes takes rook see free
positions still around equal but
actually we have very good bishop right
now but let's say it takes takes it
takes takes Y would have very good
Bishop
pollinate 5 and B would be a potential
witness not only for purple if I would
be potential weakness and if we can
activate the rook somehow we could put
some pressure as white the most
importantly pawns are on both sides of
the board Queen and King side which
favors bishop in general so this could
have maybe given some small practical
chances
or for Fabiano however of course there's
no bishop defy which also should be
considered and basically is equalized
even easier because after ruby 3 Knight
takes e5 there is one this is this
tactical idea that black has and
position simplifies very quickly and
where it's very likely just a draw but
not as if I was not easy move to find so
maybe from practical point of view we
have been better played Bishop d2 there
no that's a takes takes and Bishop takes
h6 before Daisy she takes a free roof
takes a free rock c7 and I think just
after Ruby 8 black should equalize black
should be well because of the active
idea Rudy 2 coming in but you know it's
still it's still some game maybe it's
maybe there are some practical chances
for for white given that I mean first of
all pawn pawns on b7 if I were hanging
so if you can somehow with some I know
trick make kind of like get a pawn only
one point prevent on f2 expression
second rank we may be what can somehow
win this of course it's just very
hypothetical and in general if black is
doing just just okay and it should be
around equal so this is this was the
best for blackish of d5 however foreign
play loogie free which is a good move
but he I don't think after his move
there any chances to win this with with
white because after 88 look take the
free rook takes D free fatherland plate
we should be free and this logical move
to basically preserve this h3 pawn
because this was could have been a
threat right but I think that it was a
time it was time to starting about the
equality and play Mubarak c5 if rook see
the idea of rooks fast-paced basically
play Ruby file and simply start playing
for
you know to simplify the position and
make a draw because I forbid a ch3
that's a Bishop d2 we should be six just
take on a five eliminate the the pollen
a five take this and this is just just
equal there is no any reason to worry
here with with white where like he was
just just pre draw so it was the best
moment to start thinking about equality
of course after b5 there is more so also
Bishop d2 possible but there is also a
move like Bishop Ruby 5 so I think this
was the best and clear way for for
mental equalized here or not not to also
the least to secure a draw but the thing
is I'm pretty sure that he was still
thinking about winged going for win
because he was the first man first game
so he should have looked for chances
with with black with white pieces not
with black with black pieces so he tried
to preserve this pawn but after Ruby 394
suddenly rube before and he actually
stood this bone and the white black gets
2 vs. 1 on the Queen side and move
towards 1 the quiz' is very easy to
create a pass ponder unlike for 4 versus
free on the Queen side King side for for
white especially this piece of policy
which basically clinches in a way the
entire King side and is impossible to do
here anything with white so since this
moment black is just better and it's not
easy position for black for why to
defend and Magnus wanted in very nice
nice way we see three rook takes a for
happening the game g4 know that I mean
difficult suggests a move to be honest
like if F was a safe F for somebody of
course we get for Bishop a5 but I can
just play h5 and still somehow you know
block the King side of course g4 has
this problem that is really impossible
to build his kingdom of g5 which man was
it but was but just in a moment
kingi to before which of the four be
free
rook a to finally creating the passed
pawn and finally in this moment g5
fixing the post structure and it is very
unpleasant position for for Fabiano
maybe you've best play it should be
somehow a draw but practically it's very
unpleasant to play because there are two
weaknesses one weakness is of course on
the queenside that black has white pisac
has to defend block this beep on past
beep on and also there is potential
there are potential witnesses on the
kingside because both bones are on light
squares and this bishop is so powerful
it basically looks and into Queen side
and the King so at the same time
so after kinky free the game went on
like this
and even though it seems like favela
managed to get past pawn it is simply
irrelevant because after Luke h2 rugae
for I mean first of all this pawn is
blocked here and after King Jafar is
simply tactically Magnus manages to win
this pawn kingi took in this rook out
and rock edge for basically it was
winning this pawn and let's simply
pretty much game over this from
practical point of view because even
though maybe there are still some
chances to defend it practically it's
very hard to do it because this extra
pawn also here very nice move f5 there
are all sort of tactical tricks that
what has to watch out for and I just
brought up a 5 room D 3 and so on
all of it makes it makes the position
very difficult for for white to defend
so here finally I guess Fabian blunder
this one and in the end there's
basically I'll just manage to win this
so this would be it for this game and
finally let's talk about how much time
we have there is no way I'm going to
talk about the most interesting ones I
believe the result of once so I'm gonna
talk about it right now about the game
between an apology in the voice of
Artemyev from the third one from from
this match so let me just yeah actually
for let start from this position
basically in this position this is just
beginning
I can start from beginning here you 4503
a 6 C 3 D 5 8 1895 d4 Knight of 6 there
is a pretty much theory this is like a
lop in sort of with a 6 which is
considered good for white however the
thing is it's not entirely easy to prove
the prove it is pretty solid anyway
black was play Bishop g4 and maybe is
six however is general in turn are
considered that pawn and I six is not so
needed usually blacks play with ecigs or
maybe some g4 immediately without this
pawn on e6 so in this position makes
sense it makes sense what Nepal ministry
tried to do we just move c4 basically
this move tries to show that you know
this pond is kind of like the pawn on e6
is simply not doesn't not need it there
and that he can get together to take
advantage of of this sort of extra Tempe
right now that he has because only six
being not needed however this is not not
correct I believe I just the best move
was play Bishop e2 and my opinion just
you know play regular aliping with study
bar position which definitely would have
been
which we have given some advantage as
far as I know our time if has played
this game this position many times so I
feel like maybe he I mean art Nearpod
Napa was not sure whether this is so
great especially with given so much
experience that Artemyev has had in this
position so maybe that's why he decide
to play c4 but in general I don't feel
like this is the right path because
after queenie 4 which would be to stake
c4 twin takes d4 takes takes right now
after E 5 block is simply pilar in my
opinion pawn on e6 actually is helpful
because of pollen i7 their diamond will
be possible to play net b5 will be
possible however Paul with pawn on e6
maybe high is not available so if 95 is
not available we have to retreat
passively to F 3 c2 or b3 none of them
really look great for for white and
having in mind that black has to play
move I'm black a spy if I in one movie
was wise enough for ecigs it is
definitely a good position for Artemyev
here neither 396 Knight c3 and right now
I my opinion the best move right now was
position before Bishop before it was by
far the best move and the idea is that
the short castle we want to play Bishop
takes c3 BC and Bishop f5 for instance
and we can consider playing long castle
and maybe rook Fe a
88 Knight e4 basically bones but a pawn
structure is pretty gives the gives
white gives black I mean advantage here
also is possible to play a long castle
whatever Bishop d3 it could be also very
strong so I mean I know that this type
of structure has been played in
Jeffrey's
games against magnums in the clutch
international and Joffrey had a great
chance of winning
however this is not the case here
why doesn't have great chance of winning
because Black has already developed
brackets how is it development and
normally this room should be on b1
putting some pressure
let's say here while it goes on b1 this
bishop cannot easily develop from the c8
right but Brooke on a1 black can simply
verb this bishop and play short long
Castle with great position there is no I
think the blockage simply bear here so
that's the difference and if Bishop d2
trying to maintain the pawn structure
after E for the Knight has to go either
to g5 which is not great because of
Bishop f5 h4 simply is also not great
and G runs off obviously so I think the
bug is simply better here instead play
d4 and this is why I think it was
importantly Bishop before and probably
shop d2 because it's just much better
instead pay for a ride on 92 is
available and I I think that this is
already around equal maybe even maybe
possibly slightly per for in let's say
long run because if we can block this
bishop of power Bishop on e3 will see
similar position to the one we just
discussed in Markos game against Fabiano
where he had bishop only six emperor's
pawn on e5 let's say Bishop e5 happened
short Castle Knight d4 bishop do one
long castle it seemingly all natural
moves parson I be free let's say I I
think that well the next movie should be
free White has some chances for that for
advantage here and this was right now
important moment because black work bag
bag was supposed to keep the knight on
the power of 96
after we shall be free let's say Bishop
this position stable for white but it's
not much possible it's just it's very
playable for both sides and but White
has definitely no problems unlike the
boy had problems after earlier Bishop
before move in this position that say
what can play Bishop e2 maybe h3 first
Bishop e2 Brady one rookie one maybe not
g4 which with some play on the other
hand black can prevent that from
happening Bishop e5 maybe doubling on
the D file as well Sana's could be as
coastal as some h5h for us also to gain
based on the Queen's King side pretty
much very playable position loss of life
there and both sides has some choice
some chances but it was important to
keep both pieces on the board
our team of played Bishop e6 after
Knight takes d4 rook takes d4 b3 Bishop
e3 move is actually coming of Tempe very
often and this rookies has to be kicked
out and most importantly this pawn
structure is very solid right now and
why pony for is potential weakness
because if this route comes get out of
there let's say Bishop e7 the side we
should be free rook somewhere Bishop c2
pawn if v e4 can be simply lost so our
list will be impossible to defend
because Bishop a5 is you know passive
defense and so on so in this position
are having with big mistake Robert III I
mean now keeping dice was preferable in
this position a c6 was preferable Bishop
e6 was not still so bad but right now
brood if it was very bad move best move
was simply Bishop before what could be
more natural than just developing the
bishop right after 92 Ruby 7 and I think
that here still even though I study
better our time we've had you know
basically still played on and equalized
eventually possibly a perfect play with
good place for black black Sherman to do
it without any problems however he
played rugby 3 after 94 b5
net beat to position is pretty much
right now dangerous because he played b5
and but you can't forget that his pieces
are still not developed and we normally
as general rules suggest that but first
you should try to develop pieces and
then try to create some threats and get
some create some play however here it's
sort of like reverse order of this right
was our team is doing play b5 and
place with the pieces weakening uh she
is king also so it doesn't seem like the
right approach because that's why
possibly up just suggest to move think
move I mean I don't to be honest because
it's Bishop III could be unpleasant and
Bishop c2 ideas of night c5 are coming
in it's pretty much done present
position already so he played this in
basically ruled if it was a mistake if
b5 is what happened then I'd be too and
we take c4 of course after Knight is the
free city XD free
artemyev would have had a great
conversation for this pawn for this
exchange because this position would be
you know both bones would offer good
conversation ninety-five Bishop before
or something is pretty good however
Knight takes e4 happened instead and
again this King is pretty weak if why
this just in time to play Bishop III
Bishop e2 Roxy one sudden this King will
be under huge pressure so only transfer
black would be to play Bishop takes c4
trying to trade this the night will be
text before but this position or gives
white pair of bishops and again the skin
goes on see a little bit weak so makes
us Bishop c5 I said well this pondmaster
Bishop see two rooks III just be should
be free if Brooke we would have gotten
back it's possible this pawn on e4 would
be under pressure let's say move like
rook e1 or Bishop g5 both most would be
you know pretty good and white is
definitely buyer here in the game happen
look-see free Bishop b3 and Ruby free
and b2 they repeated the line there the
moves and of course I mean I'm pretty
sure that neva didn't want to make a
draw
he still was playing for a win here rube
d7 played Artemyev and I I right now by
some reason I've never played a tree I'm
just wondering why don't we certify also
suggested suggesting right because it
looks very
he's on this one I don't have six you
take on e4 pawn maybe what black I sell
copper has some conversation connected
with 9g for our stuff some stuff like
that but like in general somehow doesn't
feel like that there is enough
conversation you can just take this pawn
for so yeah like but he played each free
so and and right now very unfortunate
moment for for our time here because he
played move rook e8 and this is the was
the final critical position right now he
could play he could have played almost
anything but rook e8 and we've decent
let's say this and not baby
we've let's say quite okay position
maybe d8 was possible maybe even h6 to
stop Bishop g5 was possibly almost back
basically anything but the movie played
rook e8 because this simply
unfortunately for our time if blunders
exchange on this diagonal because those
rooks are simply unfortunately placed
right now we should buy for and this is
simply game over and this is how Knepper
managed to win this game
roogie six takes takes the game still go
when Don and but in general manager
eventually to win it and convert this
extra exchange that he has in this game
so this will be it for this game I think
we have time for one more but definitely
not in detail definitely not in detail
because we are running a little bit out
of time right now so probably I would
just cover a little bit from this one
the second game because the one we just
discussed was the first one and in the
Popish to win this game and the third
the first game was basically clinching
them the match but the with the second
one our time of day for me I see are two
I had good chances to win this game so
let's have a look in this position last
move was h3 a changing this Bishop which
plays a frequent X of 3 y has pair of
bishops
and seemingly good chances to win the
game because you know most pawns
c3 d4 if can they can be activated it
can cause lots of damage if there are
blogs of course they'll be weak and put
objective of the attack but having pair
of bishops definitely helps in creating
some dynamic and active threat to to
black right now but in this position as
we know as I was saying many times just
very dynamic game we went to talk about
dynamics first so black has one resource
that simply equalizes the game nearly
immediately which is e 5 in this
position if I've just solved nearly all
the problems in the opening it takes d4
is the of course the main threat and
detoxifier is not possible because
Knight takes d5 and d5 move causes both
pawns to be actually in kind of like
block 26 let's say basics then rook c8
although the puzzle was C and D pawns
white C and D pawns are blocked and hope
let's say if for instance c4 maybe rook
c8 drugs C 1 B 6
this Knight can first of all can stand
on a 5 hit on c4 but also it can go to
be 75 where will be ideally placed on c5
Square and the idea of Cofer black would
be of course to f5 e for black would be
just work has very good perspective to
be bare in the end after Bishop was one
of six similar thing happens
similar ideas you know pretty much the
same stuff going on so I was thinking
maybe rook a c1 could have could have
been played here for white or to try to
kind of first of all improve the rook
and also if it takes d4 C decks before
put some pressure on this C file for the
black Queen but probably after Knight
takes d4 Queenie foreign 27 possibly
here black has the black should be just
fine
I'm not I'm not sure of the outside
outside is definitely where his
compensation but I will not be so kind
of stirred in whether there is more than
conversation to actually win the game
I'm not sure that this is actually an
advantage I think just enough
conversation to keep maintain the
equality however you know let's say
Quint if I could be interesting but the
fee sort of 25 obviously quindi five and
let's say but this already trading the
queens and you know even the mid move
like that is six trying to give one pawn
back and this should eventually end in
draw somehow this reminds me of some
Grund fault were and we're similar
positions arise and let's say you know
if the black one was on e4 and let's say
we plucked let's say maybe a cm prompt
on b6 we pretty much positions just like
from grandpa and the nopales trees
especially from ruffled and of grew fell
and he would he know well he would know
in here let's after Bishop takes takes
takes huge pre-emerge know what to do
here would like to know security draw or
you know at least be safe so this was
the best what he could do but instead he
played not easy for which is very
tempting however I believe this is not
so great because after C text before
Queen takes c4 b7 look II ate right now
look 81 and I think an underestimated
the potential of this deep own because
if this D pawn go against d5 d6 it's
pretty much came over right like this
pawn just supporting supported by this
Bishop only 7 is just crushing right
like it's just I don't see how to stop
that only way to stop that would be to
put the Queen on d7 but Queen 7 would be
very passive and usually the queen is
not such a great
locking piece overpass bones so quit
seven Queen 83 very good move b5 trying
to create a counter play d5 a v d6 Queen
d7 basically there was one interesting
moment is in this game because in this
position this is a position I won't talk
about here an Arthur we've played rook
e1 and this is a this is a believe a
mistake which keep definitely why he
still chances to win it but big part of
the advantage is just blown away because
after Queen e6 right now
Queen takes t6 pawn takes let's say if
rooted six roopd eight black has given
the pawn but because of this a be pawns
it is very likely that both pawns will
be traded for these it's not before a 4b
free trade trade rook has to come back
pawn so we will be gone it's pretty much
around equal so any rookie five this
what happened the game looks c1 d1 we
got this endgame and this is this are
gonna prune upon me she managed to
comfortably hold so coming back a little
bit to this position this this is the
problem he will in here with move remove
rook e1 instead of he could have played
for instance h4 try to provoke some of
the l play h5 afraid 5 let's say rook e1
ruby one right now is already possible
because after these days this in this
position
there was rook the rook c1 sorry there
was room d8 right in this position right
now it's not possible because policies
hang black has to waste time for king of
seven and this gives us add additional
time because the Rhino Luke 5 is the
same position by really collectors if I
phone so white has huge winning chances
here still are sometimes to equalize for
black but in general avoid should
somehow win this and the other idea here
if it would be 25 which is a little bit
let's say calm idea and a little bit
slow maybe but also he moves like rook
c6 for instance all of them maintain
lots of pressure and it wouldn't be easy
for NAPA to hold this
however he played is more given artemyev
and after this
nevermind she bothering you many
problems managed to save this and when
we need two and a half to just just a
half 4/4 time if I don't think we have
any more time for discussing the last
game so this would be the last one that
[Music]
we're going to talk about today the SEC
the we missed only one game of the last
game from the match mini match between
Martinez and Fabiano
which was extremely interesting as well
I wish we had more time to cover all of
them but I wanted to offer as much as
possible about as many games as possible
as well so I think there were lots of
things happening today involves games
and there were some mischances some lots
of drama especially with this game
Naomi artemiev they were not any of
disconnected and forfeited the game but
anyway I think there was pre instructive
and educational content and I hope you
enjoyed it and that's all I have for
today
so thank you and see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you